bonjour à tous pour notre premier étape
gastronomique nous sommes à Vierzon
devant la vitrine le tout nouveau
restaurant qui a ouvert en mars et je
vous propose d'aller retrouver la chef
qui est derrière les fourneaux et Louise
mondizier
[Musique]
bonjour Héloïse mondiz merci de nous
accueillir alors la vitrine votre
restaurant c'est pas tout à fait un
restaurant traditionnel racontez-nous un
peu ce concept que vous avez imaginé en
effet bonjour déjà
ce restaurant c'est à la fois un lieu
qui emprunte au code du traiteur de la
vente à emporter restauration rapide et
de la restauration traditionnelle parce
qu'ici tout est fait maison à partir de
produits locaux
éco-responsables circuits courts le plus
possible et donc vous pouvez manger vite
et bien vous disiez que vous vous
approvisionnez en local vous allez même
plus loin puisque vous allez cueillir
dans le jardin de vos parents certaines
herbes et fleurs je vous propose
d'ailleurs d'aller voir ce jardin à
quelques kilomètres de Vierzon dans ce
reportage réalisé avec Marion tac et
Laurence Borie
avec les fraises il y a des bonnes
fraises en ce moment et en mettant des
petites pétales comment tu les mets je
fais comme ça moi c'est mieux que là ils
sont un peu mouillés mais je l'ai je
l'ai saupoudre comme ça
des bleus et des Capucines ou de la
coriandre et Louise monzier c'est venu
faire sa cueillette du jour c'est un
vrai luxe surtout ce qui est génial
c'est que il y a une fraîcheur absolue
en fait on peut pas faire mieux en terme
de fraîcheur parce que cueillez le matin
pour être
utilisé le jour même c'est quand même
c'est quand même super quoi Sylvie sa
mère s'est prise au jeu il y a deux ans
pour sa fille elle a fait de son potager
un véritable laboratoire des saveurs
cette année j'ai expérimenté le shiso
donc la voici c'est une plante en fait
asiatique on a plusieurs shiso alors
celui-ci là il est un petit peu plus
mentholé il est plus doux que le que le
rouge et Héloïse préfère le rouge donc
je lui referai un petit peu de
de rouge mais en même temps je le trouve
très esthétique celui-ci
et c'est juste piquant à souhait
véritable passionné Sylvie conduit son
potager en biodynamie on y trouve des
plantes sauvages méconnues que le public
est invité à découvrir tous les
après-midi de mai à septembre nous
sommes de retour avec vous Héloïse
bonziès et vous vous apprêtez à nous
faire un une recette qui va être tout à
fait appropriée pour l'été exactement
c'est une salade de pois chiches avec
des pois chiches locaux la première
étape je vais couper mes tomates
et l'avantage c'est que c'est une
recette qu'on peut quand même facilement
reproduire même si on n'est pas un
expert en cuisine ah oui oui
complètement complètement moi j'aime
bien les recettes qui sont faciles qui
ont du goût ce qui est important en fait
ce qui va ce qui va faire toute la
différence ça va être la saison
donc je vais ajouter mon concombre
sur le dessus
mes petites tomates
et puis et puis après je vais hacher mes
herbes
ça c'est très très parfum mais est-ce
que vous venez de couper oui c'est le
fameux
après il y a différentes variétés de
shiso
et ce Shoo là est un peu citronné qu'en
frais il a un peu différent mais il y a
toujours cette petite pointe de cumin
donc là je vais faire ma vinaigrette
maintenant
alors on va mettre
4 cuillères à soupe d'huile
c'est de l'huile d'olive
après je vais mettre deux cuillères à
soupe de vinaigre balsamique là j'ai un
vinaigre balsamique qui est très
concentré très très sucré donc je vais
aussi rajouter une cuillère à soupe de
jus de citron
et puis je vais mettre mes épices
je vais mettre une cuillère à café de
zata
et une pincée comme ça de graines de
nigelle ça va venir croquer un petit peu
donner de la texture et de la mâche
quand on va manger la salade
je mélange dans cette recette oui c'est
ça voilà donc je fais du local tout en
partant voyager ailleurs grâce aux
épices
donc là je vais verser ma sauce
sur ma salade
mais la petite touche finale parce que
ça en plus vous l'avez cueilli ce matin
dans le jardin de votre maman Sylvie
c'est ça voilà je suis allé chercher
ces petits boutons
voilà et on a terminé notre salade
superbe et ben merci beaucoup Héloïse
d'avoir été notre invité et de nous
avoir montré cette recette très estivale
demain votre page gastronomique continue
on va tenter de percer les secrets de
nos grands-mères berrichonne